i will guess that you have had the same
experience that i have had where
uh the pandemic has strained
relationships that felt extremely solid
beforehand but it has also forged a
tremendous number of very high quality
connections with people who have
extraordinary
capacities and who amplify each other's
humanity that's been
the silver lining for i think many of us
is that we
we have
met
so many
high quality courageous insightful
people yourself among them
in my case
um
and so that's a very powerful force i
hear you saying
that maybe the
uh the troubling authoritarian mass that
it could be rational in the sense that
it creates this reaction that's very
high quality
i think they are both rational and you
know uh one of the things that's hard to
see evolutionarily is we tend to think
well what is the best strategy and the
point is well you've got strategies and
counter strategies and uh
you know i have written on my my notes
here mass versus anti-mass because there
is something about the process of the
people
who uh do appear to have resisted the
madness and to have uh shown such
strength of character that has some of
the same characteristics right um
we have scratched our itch in a very
different way
um but nonetheless
the camaraderie
in your description
it is the terror of
loneliness and
the inability to interpret the world
that drives people to scratch that itch
by signing on to a nonsense story that
gives the promise of some kind of
salvation
and
that thing created a world in which some
of us became obsessed with making sense
from actual evidence difficult as that
is
and it created a camaraderie of a
different kind so basically the point is
everybody's looking for camaraderie and
there are a couple different paths one
of them is easy and very dangerous the
other is uh
well dangerous to the individual at an
extraordinary level um but nonetheless
does bring you in the same kind of
context and it is very uh
reassuring to discover that there are
others for example
well go ahead
now i still i think that there is
or we should watch out that we do not
become
a real mass just because
um there is a i think the
the most important distinction between a
sound and fruitful group formation and a
mass formation is that in a group in a
in a
in a good group formation
there is on the one hand
a certain bond between between the
individual and the collective but also
the bonds between individuals are strong
and there is a real solidarity between
the individuals as well and i think
that
i also i
i discovered many new friendships during
during the crisis and i in my
experience
it existed of really strong bonds
between the individuals i don't think
that i started to form a mass with other
people uh like look when you and me are
talking now we can have a different
opinion yes i was just going to say this
that's how we know this isn't a mass
yes
we haven't agreed on some abstraction
even you know if we were going to right
the group of people that we are now
mutually in contact with
have resonated with mass formation as an
idea and we have seen it
move around so if there was an idea that
we were all going to sign on to and not
notice you know
that there was an incompleteness here or
a paradox there that would be it but
you're right we're not doing that and
that is
uh maybe that's the uh
the check that we need to know that we
are not in a mass is are we holding each
other's feet to the fire or not right
and i don't want to be part of any
uh group that isn't willing to honorably
hold each other's feet to the fire for
one thing that's how we make sense
that's the whole point of the endeavor
right
we will we you know we will freeze
ourselves in place with a narrative that
isn't true
if we don't uh
pressure test it and uh challenge each
other
indeed
yes but i think suddenly it seems to me
to be a very attractive idea or a very
attractive question like
indeed on the one hand we could say
that
from a rational point of view the
smartest choice
is to go along with the masses
and to feel protected by the masses
on the other hand we could also say no
it's the other way around it's better to
belong to the small group because if you
do the right thing as a small group if
you stick to your ethical principles
you will go through this fast process of
evolution which has been described by
many people and which maybe is the is
the real destiny of the human being to
become an ethically aware human being
uh
with an enlightened mind
um
and
yeah
perfect
um and you know i keep trying to explain
to people who you know
as i'm sure happens with you people will
come up and they will say
you're very brave i admire you this that
and the other i try to explain
this situation left no choice i
literally do not know how i would have
done the other thing right i wouldn't
have been able to stand it for five
minutes
and and so
it is
that which you know
does you know it does rob it of a
certain amount of courage i didn't have
a choice i didn't make the choice to do
this it just simply was the only thing
that that was tolerable
but it does raise this other question
one of the things i saw so i saw
two mass formations in a row right
there's the mass formation
uh around woke ideology
which
did the same thing it created a
group of people who
uh came together from very different
perspectives
uh battled the irrationality of the
claims
and it was it was a wonderful
chapter
then
when kovid came
it shocked me because it took the group
of people
who had
formed this
anti-mass
to the woke ideology and it divided it
some of the people who
[Music]
saw right through the woke ideology fell
right in line
with the
uh
i mean i call it uh i call them
medically woke
right it's equally irrational and yet
and they've demonstrated the capacity to
see through irrational things
and the courage to do it and yet in this
case
something about this story was in their
blind spot
i can't i can't understand it um maybe
maybe you do why is it that people who
have resistance to this in one context
don't have resistance in another
yes i think that the the the emergence
of the work culture in our society was
like a preparatory face for the large
mass formations that still have to come
because
um
in my opinion the corona crisis was the
first real mass formation exactly
because it has this
baffling characteristic that it split
all the existing groups into that's the
the signature of a real mass formation
it is energetically so strong that it
re-divides
reorganizes the entire social structure
uh but yes and and and once once one
real mass formation emerged in society
very often a second one and a third one
and a fourth one follows just because
the mass formation
recreates
recreates the conditions that made it
emerge
mass formation started
on the basis of loneliness and
disconnectedness but the mass formation
itself
leads to even much more disconnectedness
and loneliness while it seems to do the
opposite in the beginning it destroys
the social bond further and after the
mass formation there is even more lonely
people more disconnected people which
very often makes
that a second mass formation and a third
one emerges so shortly after the first
one
uh ceased to or or disappeared a little
bit in the background so um
[Music]
i believe that
uh the the phenomenon is very well known
if a real mass information emerges then
something happens something something
very specific specific happens in
certain people which is referred to
as a mental surrender people who were
convinced
uh
anti-totalitarians or anti-fascists or
no matter what
very often suddenly become fascists
themselves as soon as a fascist mass
formation emerges just because they
don't like the they don't have the
mental energy or the psychological
strength
to to prevent that order all the energy
has sucked away from their mental
representations and invested in the
mental and only this limited set of
mental representations that is shared by
the group so in many people i know
personally many people who wrote article
many people i knew i know a few people
who wrote
articles about the dangers of
technocratic totalitarianism about
uh
the the danger of the dangers of extreme
collectivism and conformism and then the
corona crisis started and in the brink
of an eye they conformed to the
mainstream narrative and they declared
everyone crazy we didn't go along with
the mainstream narrative so
that's that's the strange thing
and in my in
in my case exactly well not the opposite
happened but something different happens
i had exactly the same experience as the
one that you described and i i talked
about it in numerous podcasts before
this one that in the beginning of the
crisis
i realized immediately i will speak out
i have no other option and i will
continue speaking out no matter what it
it it brings
to me or no matter what the consequences
are i just immediately knew if i don't
speak out now
i will never have to speak out and i
will do it i will just do it and i
started to speak almost without
i didn't have the feeling that i chose
for it i knew it i will speak out
right
in my case i would say
i had had that discussion with myself
decades ago
right i think in part in my case growing
up as a jew
as close to the end of world war ii as i
did i was born in 1969 so a quarter
century later but nonetheless close
enough that it was on people's minds
many people i knew had seen it
and my basic feeling was
i looked at all of the people
who waited too long to speak out who
did something that
leaves me frustrated even hearing what
their response was and my thought was uh
there i will not i will not go along
with such a thing right even even at the
cost of my life i would much rather
take my best shot
and not be left with the question of why
didn't i do more
than uh
to be stuck and
so anyway at the point that you get
to the thing
you know the choice is just made
yes
as well i think because my family also
has this
well tradition of speaking out no matter
what the coast is certain people in my
in my ancestors did that
and
um
i also think that i also like when i
started to work at university
uh i and i and i saw how how many flawed
research there was i immediately started
to review it and i started i i i tried
to show what the problems were with this
kind of research and after after two
years at university 90 of the people was
very angry with me and the other 10
really respected me and
and i i had this
also there i i in in that period
throughout the last 20 years
i really became used to having 90 of the
people against me and trying to continue
to speak out in a very quiet way without
trying to hurt anyone and
being respectful as much as possible but
still i always refused to shut up and
when the corona crisis started i knew
like look
this time i will speak in public space
i used to speak out and and only in the
academic world but i knew like this one
i will speak out in public space and i
don't know if that was also something
that you experienced but
while i continued to speak out people
were throwing mud at me here in the
belgian newspapers it happens all the
time even now
constantly uh
the
the the
there are if the mainstream media
talk about me it's always in a very
negative and condescending way and um
but as i
practiced and as a and as i as i tried
to continue to speak out without really
becoming aggressive myself or without
just
calm and quiet i really had this feeling
that i felt as if a
very
warm and soft power grew stronger than
me and
you know
this experience in itself for me
compensates for everything that i have
lost in the crisis which is not so much
i have been excommunicated from certain
groups at university
um
i won't be too dramatic about it
and but but but still no matter what i
would lose
i would want to
give it uh if i have this phenomenon in
return that you feel the soft
power that is increasing in myself and
that that for me as the essence of life
actually um
i agree and i uh i wish i knew how
to
convey what you're describing to a
larger audience i i will say it's very
interesting to hear
um that you have
polarized the institutions you've been
part of i've had that same phenomenon
i've polarized every institution i've
been a part of and you know when people
who don't who haven't had that
experience hear it they think how
terrible that you're polarizing and the
answer is
no i want the respect of the people that
i think
their respect means something right if
you polarize an institution and all of
the people
who are
uh
you know phonies or corrupt or cowards
if they all you know line up against you
and the people that you actually admire
are like
ready to acknowledge yeah
you make sense then the answer is well
what else would you have done do you
want the respect of people who aren't
respectable i don't right and so the yes
the um
what you are describing what i think i
have also experienced
is a training program for something it's
a developmental experience that
generates certain
characteristics that if you have them
you're not eager to trade them for
something else right
right i mean i feel the same way in some
sense about uh
you know i have what people describe as
dyslexia
it interfered with my ability to do
normal school work
but i don't look at it as something that
i lost i looked at it as something that
forced me into patterns that i uh
wouldn't know what to do without and so
um anyway i yeah
the path of somebody who polarizes
institutions is not necessarily fun
hour to hour but uh viewed on a long
time scale it does
it's very clarifying and um
i wish more people
realized that and didn't fear uh
causing people to
reject them
yes yes yes i agree i agree
there is something
there is this um
in the talmud says if i'm not mistaken
if a human being
does not speak
does not articulate the words that
emerge
in him or herself and that seem to be
honest and sincere verse
then he will slowly start to lose
his soul
and
i do believe the opposite is true as
well if you practice and if you
constantly try to articulate the words
that you consider to be sincere and
honest words no matter what the
consequences are and no matter how the
group reacts to it
then you will
slowly start to
be more aware of your own existence as a
human being you will start to feel
stronger you will feel your real
identity you will
be less in need of all kinds of ego and
and and
fake identities and i think for me the
human being
uh
is intrinsically
dependent on the quality of his speech i
think that the speech
the quality of our speech and then i
don't mean the aesthetical qualities but
the the sincerity and of speech and the
courage
of your words
determines in a straightforward way
the strength of your soul and the
strength of your mind i think and i
think the better we realize that the
more we know that
maybe we should tolerate that
they take everything away of us in the
end
uh but we should make sure that they
don't take away our humanity and and and
that we
if we if we have to die that we doubt
that we die with our principles and not
without
um
uh
that's something that i well i became
more much more aware of during this
crisis like like what
is important and what is not important
uh in in
this life here
yeah i think that's uh beautifully said
and uh
at the risk of tarnishing it i will
put it in what i take to be the
evolutionary context
um you know people are often
prone to you know ask what's really
special about humans right and they come
up with all kinds of things but really
in the end it is speech and the reason
that it is speech is because that allows
two minds to share ideas abstract ideas
and this is the core of what we do that
other creatures cannot right
um so anyway in saying the quality of
your speech and
the uh
the integrity of it and uh i would argue
the capacity of it to convey important
nuance
you're really talking about the thing
about us that
uh
unites
the individual with something else right
speech
yes you can talk to yourself and you
know
i think a lot of us who care about
speech probably do but
um but the point is
to say that your speech is important is
to imply that your relationship the
integrity of your relationship and your
capacity to interact with somebody in a
deep high bandwidth fashion is also at
the core of you know the most meaningful
element of being human and i 100 agree
with that
um
i think that our relationship
the social bond between humans is always
intrinsically linguistic in nature
because we can't we have no other option
than to constantly try to interpret the
other
the expressions on the face uh
everything
is interpreted by us we have no other
option we constantly do and so it's it's
it's it's indeed
we are linguistic entities for each
other
and we can only connect and to each
other through language uh
or our the nature of our connection is
linguistic
um intrinsically
um
yes i think
the art of speech
is the answer i think to all
totalitarianism
[Music]
you